in the city of adigrad
the general hospital may be the only
thing that works
the doors are open and the wards are
full
and the staff do what they can in this
war-ravaged corner of tigre
but there is so much pain in this
dilapidated building
[Music]
in an airless room a nurse offers
treatment to women
who have been raped by soldiers and
militiamen
and it was full when we arrived
sister amina has met more than 200
victims in the past two months
and she has heard and experienced their
stories
and a warning some may find the
following extremely distressing
that's a different enzyme as allah abdul
hamid s
is
the women find some comfort in this
overcrowded sanctuary
where they're offered pregnancy tests
and checked for hiv
but many are too ashamed to come here
this is 31 year old miriam
mariam says she's convinced 30 women to
seek treatment here
but the trauma she's experienced may
never heal
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
collapse it this is dr haggos the
hospital gynecologist
he told me sexual violence is used by
soldiers
as a way to fight this war but the
hospital
can only treat a small number of women
yeah
it's now become beyond our capacity
those who are being raped
are also getting pregnant most of them
actually they are pregnant
out of this 200 around 106 are pigment
106 of them are pregnant so imagine
it's very it's beyond our capacity to uh
because they have the pregnancy has to
be terminated
that it's it's becoming beyond our
capacity to target all these pregnancies
as we made our way out we were stopped
by a woman
who said she'd been raped along with her
89 year old grandmother
it was an act of punishment she said by
soldiers who
thought her husband was an opposition
tplf
fighter
[Music]
[Music]
reprisal attacks by ethiopian troops and
their allies
have become increasingly common and as
we left atigrat
we witnessed the aftermath of another
two army vehicles had been caught in an
ambush
dead body and a pair of minibuses had
been stopped on the road
the passengers were ordered out said
doctors without borders
and the men were shot in an act of
revenge
in the regional capital michele we found
a 27 year old woman
who has suffered in an unimaginable way
she boarded a bus destined for adegrat
when eritrean troops
pulled her off and raped her for the
following
ten days
after they were finished the soldiers
tried to throw her away
she told me
i think you're incredibly strong
embraced
her account defies explanation the
inhumanity
cannot be understood and these stories
weigh heavily
on those who live here john sparks sky
news
in mckelley
you